let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not liberty
you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the tony
michaels podcast and this is tony
michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
well happy
happy happy hump day
it's wednesday
four o'clock eastern three hawk central
you know what that means you know what
time it is
it is time for let's talk the tony
michaels podcast thank you for joining
me
today
we are very excited
about our episode
that we have in store for you
so stay with us all two hours you know
that we have a new two hour format we're
with you all two hours
but today the second hour we have a very
very very special interview heidi kuda
of the radicalized podcast
gives us the lowdown and she talks about
general mike flynn
and the q anon
trump cult you know that jfk crt voodoo
type cult thing she gives us the rundown
of the cult what it is what it isn't
what their goals are what they're gonna
be we also play trivia which is very
important it's become a very important
feature
of the podcast of the show
is trivia we also um we want to talk
about this week's bonehead of the week
so me and gabe in the second half of the
first hour we'll talk about the moon end
of the week for next week you guys can
go vote on it at tony michael's pod
the poll is over there for you to vote
for the bonehead of the week so we will
talk about that
at the bottom of the second or the
second half of the first hour
we also want to mention now that we're
at a two-hour format and we're getting
all kinds of new stuff you guys can see
a lot of new stuff is happening we have
gabe sanchez as the executive producer
we're doing interviews every single week
with the trivia
funny videos funny commercials you guys
have seen some of the satire we're
trying to do
get you to laugh while you're you know
having to eat this [ __ ] sandwich of this
fascism in this country
it really is a disgusting [ __ ] sandwich
and we had a lot a lot
of the [ __ ] sandwich this week from not
only uh bobert but marjorie taylor green
matt gets and a few others so we'll
probably get that today in the [ __ ] list
and some of the talk today
but because we have all these things i
want to tell you
i want to thank all the people out there
that have given to the podcast upgrade
fund we have this little fund on the
tonymichaels.com our budget was about
seventeen hundred and twenty dollars for
some new lights new microphones you can
see we got a new microphone some new
equipment some new software that we're
trying to bring you some better
production new lights those sorts of
things
so if you can give 50 cents a dollar two
dollars however much you want to give
even if you can't give anything that is
fine keep liking keep sharing keep
commenting give us five star reviews
over on your favorite directory that you
listen to the podcast on give us a
thumbs up on the youtube right now if
you're watching on youtube thumbs up
thumbs up thumbs up and subscribe to all
those places that would help too but if
you want the production to get better go
over to thetonymichaels.com
check out the podcast upgrade fund it's
at the very top link
and give what you can or just give us a
thumbs up and a thanks we appreciate all
that and we appreciate you being with us
here
on the tony michaels podcast every
single wednesday three o'clock central
four o'clock eastern
as well as the [ __ ] list roundup you
know we do a daily show a daily stream
where we surf the trendy trends and the
tweety tweets of the day it's called the
[ __ ] list roundup it's on twitter and
twitch
so don't miss that one either it's every
single weekday every single one noon
eastern 11 central
so check us out there because we gather
up all the [ __ ]
that we need to put on the list for the
week
and really honestly
this week there's really really really
really one big issue that keeps standing
out to me
and it's these fascist
absolute
delusional obsession
with firearms
and posting pictures of them with them
and their families in front of christmas
trees
some of these people have made it on our
bonehead of the week this week and even
last week
right after we had
a school shooting in michigan and we're
going to talk about that today on the
[ __ ] list and we're going to talk about
the talk because i think this is really
important that we dedicate most of the
first hour to this subject
i've talked about the gun control and
this obsession with gun culture in the
past on the podcast and on other content
that i have
and i think we need to not
stop talking about it
we need to not
deaden our blow
when we hear a report of a school
shooting and four children killed by
another child
we need to not forget it we need to make
sure
that we know that this is an issue this
is a problem and it's killing children
for [ __ ] sake
so i think this is a very very very
important issue to continue
to talk about
on the [ __ ] list today and also we'll
talk more about it on the talk but we
also want to bring up uh you see you
guys seen that there was and this is
part of this fascist gun culture
you know macho machismo fragile white
male [ __ ]
it's what all this is it's all one and
the same
it's all delusional q anon garbage that
they keep peddling that's leaking into
the minds of americans
diluting
the simpleness
of white america
but this patriot farce or patriot front
or whatever the hell this
u-haul type
fascist nazis the word these these
u-haul kkk you've seen them they came in
and u-haul trucks and that's [ __ ]
ridiculous
but we have to pay attention we cannot
look away we cannot look away so stay
with us stay with us today because
you're not going to want to miss this
show
you're probably going to want to watch a
little bit of it twice you might even
want to watch it and then listen to it
as well but stay right there we'll be
right back with the shitless
you sit your ass down sit the flip down
we're not finished the tony michaels
podcast we'll be right back
i am so excited about a new movie you
guys have probably heard about this
movie the supporters it's starring the
good liars this movie is [ __ ]
hilarious and i think it might have been
a mistake but for some reason i got an
advanced screening of this movie it's
about two doofuses that get wrapped up
in the maca trump bumping gulf [ __ ]
boneheads the characters names are
derrick and dale and they have a podcast
called the derrick and dale show that
they do out of the back of a minivan
that they live out of they're pissing
and jugs
they're chasing their dreams of having
this hit cable show on fox news and when
that all gets crushed they decide to do
their own research and travel all across
the country during the 2020 presidential
campaign armed with only their white
male fragility and a camera
they run into the likes of andrew yang
tom steyer elizabeth warren president
joe biden marjorie hoof foot green don
booger sugar junior they even have a
close encounter in the film with the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy pants
himself donald trump is in the film you
cannot miss this one it is a
fantastically funny movie starring the
good liars you know these comedians from
their viral videos about occupy wall
street manga rallies and even the
january 6 insurrection that footage from
the january 6 insurrection is in the
film do not miss this movie it is
released on november 4th go to
thesupportersmovie.com in reserve so you
see the movie first you have to see this
[ __ ] movie the good liars present in
association with midas pictures
executive producers michael rappaport
the supporters don't
[ __ ] miss it
the tony michaels podcast wednesdays at
4 p.m eastern 3 p.m central watch live
on youtube on twitter and twitch
download on apple and spotify now here's
tony
welcome back to the show thanks for
staying with us through the break
you guys remember this supporters movie
it was great i figured we'd stump for it
again
give it its due it's it's worth its
weight it really ties in today with this
with having heidi on and for the
interview talking about mike flynn and
the the manga cult and this q anon stuff
uh because in the movie they really kind
of work through
in a satirical way how some of this q
anon maga cult stuff started to happen
and how the cult gets perpetuated
so check out that movie and go to again
the supporters movie dot com to check
that out
but right now let's get into the [ __ ]
list the [ __ ] list
so we seen
last week
uh an unfortunate tragedy where
a young child
gets a hold of a weapon
um
i really don't even want to say the name
on the air
because i'm tired of hearing the name
of the killer
but this young child was given access to
a to a a weapon of war
by his manga trump-humping irresponsible
parents
the school warned them the school
wanted them to take him out of school
and they resisted
which only resulted
in this child to use this weapon of war
which a child's brain
does not have the capacity to understand
some of these things
and we've seen
that these parents are going to be
charged
with involuntary manslaughter the
craziest part about it all
is that not only did they provide this
weapon for them on a black friday sale
but they almost encouraged
through text messages this behavior from
this child
and it perpetuated in a situation which
is a tragedy
that four other children got killed
and then when the going got tough on
these parents
because they may have been culpable
and the prosecutor charges them with
involuntary manslaughter
when the going gets tough they abandoned
their child
which
to be honest they abandoned him long
before then and and it's all this gun
cultured [ __ ]
the guns are more important
than the children the guns are more
important than other people's children
the guns are more important than
education
because guns guns guns guns guns rather
it's to own the libs or
sell protection this is not self defense
this is not self protection anymore this
is all [ __ ] this idea that they want
to hold their weapons of war and they
want to train their children to use
weapons of war for self-protection
is [ __ ] absolute 100
horse [ __ ]
and we see it no more clear than these
[ __ ]
q anon maga trump pumping boneheads in
congress
posting their i don't know i guess it's
a christmas card or our christmas tweet
or whatever the [ __ ] they think they're
doing they think they're being really
[ __ ] cute
by owning the libs look my kids have
automatic weapons in their hands and i'm
gonna take a picture in front of a
christmas tree because what would jesus
do but take a picture of ourselves with
our automatic rifles in front of our
christmas tree
this is really [ __ ] dumb this gun
culture [ __ ] has gotten way out of hand
and i feel like that the majority of the
three is sick of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
we are literally training children
in schools
what to do during an active studies when
an active shooter comes into school and
not only not only to try to save their
lives from the maniac that's running
around with a rifle because their
parents have encouraged this type of
culture
but we're also training the active
shooters themselves
we have a situation in this country
where there is a culture in our schools
where we are training
the active shooters
and we are training
the people who are going to be killed by
the active shooters all at once
these sheriff's departments go to these
schools and they hold these active
shooter drills to train these children
what to do so they don't lose their
lives
when i was a kid
we would do tornado drills
we would do earthquake drills
we would do
fire drills
these are things mostly out of control
of human beings
but you have to train children
when something happens that is out of
our control
to be safe
and we literally are training our
children
to dodge the bullets of their classmates
while we at the same exact time train
the classmates that are going to shoot
their other classmates what is going to
happen while they're trying to shoot and
kill their other classmates
that's what we're [ __ ] how [ __ ]
demented is this
when will it end
when will we stop we can stop this we do
not have to do this [ __ ]
oh well criminals will get guns no
matter what you we are not having mass
school shootings by criminals you dumb
[ __ ]
this isn't some kind of [ __ ]
drug dealer that comes off the street
and goes into school and mows down
children it is children
killing
children
when will you open your [ __ ] eyes and
realize what we are doing to
our children in this country huh
what's it gonna take oh we thought sandy
hook and then stoneman douglas and now
in michigan
and we'll see what kind of justice
that we get from the parents that are
responsible for this school shooting
because at the heart of it that's the
truth
the kid needed help
he s he was seeking help apparently
writing notes
that said help me
the school trying to get him help for
his parents
and they went la la la la la la la la la
maga
trump trump trump trump trump trump
trump we love guns we love guns
we don't care about our kid or our lives
or other people's children's lives let
them die
guns more important than lives we're
pro-life no you're not
it's all a bunch of [ __ ] horse [ __ ]
all of it
and you're playing into this gun culture
you're totally playing in to this
[ __ ] fragile white privilege [ __ ]
gun culture cause that's what it is
you don't think that this has to do with
kyle rittenhouse
ha ha think again
you don't think that this has to do with
police brutality on black people haha
think again
this is our nation's culture
other nations look at us and go holy
[ __ ]
they have children killing children with
weapons of war
in america
while they're learning science and math
in english
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] show
and we're standing around wondering how
we can't get [ __ ] people to
understand why a vaccine
is gonna prevent a deadly pathogen from
spreading around no wonder we can't
break through
we have a mental illness problem in this
country
it is a [ __ ] disease
a bad [ __ ] disease
i'm not talking about the coronavirus of
the new [ __ ] variant
i'm talking about this white privileged
gun culture [ __ ]
and we almost we almost didn't even see
it on the news
four children killed in in michigan
by a 15 year old student
who showed signs the school even even
was raising red flags and i don't know
if the school is responsible for part of
this or not it's hard to even determine
the facts
because i'm so [ __ ] deadened
by the fact that we
it's just another average tuesday of 15
year olds kill another 15 year olds in a
[ __ ] high school with a weapon of war
well this is america
you people aren't [ __ ] patriots
you people out there standing in front
of your stupid [ __ ] christmas trees
with your children and their and your
stupid [ __ ] rifles thinking that
you're [ __ ] owning libs
and that you're doing your good deed
by being a patriot
to show your second amendment right
that's not your second amendment right
you're not it's not self-defense anymore
it's aggression
it's aggression
and now you've brought your children
into it
your children are now being trained
as active shooters
that's what you're doing
you [ __ ] boneheads in congress
it's that culture what do you think
rittenhouse was
his mom put him in the car with the gun
and drove him
his mom
a teenager
that's what we're okay with
you know cause it's tuesday in america
it's thursday in america
why not dodge some bullets today
in your high school math class
sounds like fun doesn't it
this is what we expect our children to
believe is a democracy this is what we
expect our children to believe is that
we actually care about their [ __ ]
safety
in this country that we care about them
that we want them to be safe
from each other
shooting each other with with
semi-automatic rifles with handguns
and that's the thing they're going to
say oh you don't know anything about
guns see you
you those guns in those pictures or this
or that you don't know [ __ ] about guns
tony
you don't know [ __ ]
that's why you're so stupid that's why
that's why you're wrong
in the 1990s
there was a vent in colorado
at columbine high school
and when that school shooting happened
this entire country went what the [ __ ]
just happened
and ever since then we've gotten better
and better and better
at doing active shooter training to try
to save lives
and all the while training the shooters
themselves
and here we are
and at first the gun lobby's like oh
[ __ ] this is going to be horrible for
business
this is going to be absolutely horrible
people are going to be so [ __ ]
frightened of guns they're gonna stop
buying them
boy was the gun lobby wrong
school shootings weren't bad for
business
they were good for business
and the reason why is because reasonable
people went well maybe maybe what we
should do is keep guns out of the hands
of children maybe what we should do is
have reasonable gun laws like universal
background checks and [ __ ] like that
and what the low percentage of the
population the fascist the [ __ ]
boneheads the people who are standing in
front of christmas trees posing for
pictures with their family and their
family of rifles as if the rifles are
more important to them than their
[ __ ] families themselves
what happened
those people get scared that they're
going to take our guns away from us
well earl we can't have our guts taken
away from us
so let's go buy more
and every school shooting every mass
shooting
and increase gun sales and increased
ammo sales
and all of a sudden the gun lobby and
the nra is like hey
you know this mass shooting this school
shooting this ain't bad for business
this is good for profits
don't believe me
go state by state and watch
go state by state and watch what laws
were taken apart
that allowed children that allowed
adults to get their hands on weapons to
murder other people
this isn't for hunting it's not for
self-defense anymore it is a white
privilege gun culture in this country
that is a disease
it's a disease folks
and i i don't have the exact answers to
inoculate us of this disease
i wish i did i wish there was some kind
of
magic potion
that could cure us
something tells me we're so far deep in
even if we start to try to undo some of
the some of the horrible things that we
have done to our children in this
country with this white privilege gun
culture
i don't i don't know
how long it would take to undo it to
unravel some of this so our children
don't have to go to school and be
trained in arithmetic and how to dodge a
[ __ ] bullet
because that's the truth
two plus two is four
and two plus two shots are four people
killed in my school my classmates by
another classmate
you got it children are killing children
with weapons
of war
and you [ __ ] are gonna stay on
my [ __ ] [ __ ] list
you can
ben damn well better believe that you
will remain on the [ __ ] list here at the
tony michaels podcast
again i don't have the answers they're
smart people out there
like shannon watts
to name one
and there's a few others
that have really good ideas they know
what they're doing
and we need to support them and their
effort
all these parents from the sandy hook
tragedy and the stoneman douglas tragedy
that are working inch by inch they work
so hard and so long
and they barely get a [ __ ] drop
of results
to keep the guns at a hands of children
to kill other [ __ ] children in
schools
they worked so
[ __ ] hard so long months years
just to maybe get two words changed in a
law
so they can try to prevent one [ __ ]
death
and it's all worth it
and until we all get off our asses and
realize that this is a democracy
and the majority should rule
because that's what we're dealing with
is minority rule the majority of
americans don't want this type of [ __ ]
they're sick of this [ __ ]
they don't want children killing
children with guns in schools
anything to prevent that
absolutely anything
you don't have to give up your freedom
and your rights
to make sure that children aren't
[ __ ] murdering other children in
schools
at the bear [ __ ] minimum
the bear [ __ ] minimum
so keep supporting
those causes out there
keep pushing
because that is the only way we make
this happen is pro-democracy people who
are on who are on the side of the
majority
not
not just about this single issue
of school shootings but
gun safety in general
we have to keep pushing
we have to keep fighting
and maybe maybe one day
our children will go grow up in a
country where they can go back to being
scared of tornadoes and fires and
earthquakes as opposed to having to
learn how to dodge bullets
in schools
i'll be right back after this
you sit your ass down sit the flip down
we're not finished the tony michaels
podcast we'll be right back
headline
[Music]
president joe biden releases 50 million
barrels of oil from the strategic
petroleum reserve to lower gas prices
for american families thanks brandon
[Applause]
[Music]
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels we're back to the king of
brilliant this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
welcome back to let's talk to tony
michaels podcast
joining me now
is the famous
gabe sanchez our executive producer on
the show
gabe we have a really really really good
interview
uh today with heidi kuda
and i i i just i i want to say
that she really dives deep into some of
this q anon
mike flynn uh just this culty voodoo
type stuff
and and i i i i just came off uh
a huge rant there um uh but i think it's
worth noting that we should probably do
that every day of the week unfortunately
we do have to concentrate on some other
issues but i actually think that some of
this q anon voodoo culture because we
kind of seen this with the michigan
shooter and his parents
what what
this culture that has been created by
maga and q anon and this this trump like
culty [ __ ]
yeah it's uh
it's unfortunate to see that this is
where our kind of society has headed
um
the biggest thing is the obsession you
know with
guns i i don't understand it you know
like you it's not meant for hunting you
know and i think the biggest thing that
people say is you know if you do need it
for hunting and i completely agree with
this if you do need it for hunting then
you suck at hunting
right like you do not need
to have an assault rifle to mow down
a deer
to put it on the wall right like if
you're really good at what you do then
you should be able to do it with another
you know a rifled or something like that
but for people to you know fantasize and
uh
compensate for any sort of issue that
they may have with a gun to prove
themselves as some like alpha male
is ridiculous
it's asinine and and at the end of the
day
it's caused
the loss of lives from many children
adults children like you know
it's i don't know their obsession is is
is idiotic ass and i like i i don't know
how else to describe it without yeah i
don't know
well i mean i mean we seen it this week
with the you know after this shooting
happened we seen uh one member of
congress
for sure uh thomas massey i believe his
name is yeah um
he posted a picture did he post it on
twitter originally is that where or was
it like on instagram or something i
think it was on twitter uh yeah i saw it
originally where i saw was on twitter
right so so it's basically him and his
family and i'm not gonna show that
picture because if i go to the twitter
feed there might be a lot of other
versions of it um that other people have
created
in satire or try to try to make fun of
it
that have other things and guns uh in
these people's hands but i i will say
that
that uh even those uh satirical pictures
that are trying to
uh make light of what it is uh and being
inappropriate
none of that would have happened if
thomas massey didn't think that to own
the libs
he would do this picture with his family
where
his little children and his teenage
children
just days after a teenager
murders four children in a school and
the parents are charged with basically
an accessory to manslaughter here
um
i i just i can't even [ __ ] hardly put
it together in my mind and we you know
we try to laugh about this stuff we try
to laugh it off we try to make fun of it
um but it is this culture thing because
we've seen it leak down to another
member of congress who's trying to out
do the other crazy [ __ ] right and lauren
bobert and i actually um and it's not
even it's not even that it's it's also
the fact that like aftermath like it
the gop timing is
intentionally
uh shitty right so you have the shooting
and a few days later massey says
hey let's take a family photo season's
greetings merry christmas whatever the
[ __ ] they want to say and they're all
holding different weapons
and
uh then you had candace owens online and
she was like can somebody with a
non-left leftist deranged mind
explain to me what the big deal is and
why everyone's so mad at massey for you
know second amendment right or whatever
she said right
and it's
there's a part of me that's like are you
so disconnected like you you clearly are
doing this
to
to ruffle feathers like you know
right that don't own the libs type stuff
yeah did to do this within days of a
mass shooting
is
is so in poor taste right and it's so
disgusting
and vile but then to have someone like
candace owens be like oh i don't get why
everyone's so upset does this make any
sense this is insane
playing dumb basically which is even
worse than the act of doing it almost
right
so here's here's actually uh i'm gonna
bring it up here here is the dipshit's
tweet um because everyone says oh don't
show it but i i think it's worth showing
hers and the reason why it's worth
showing hers is because
she she she not only watched thomas
massey
uh do this and what the
what the narrative was and what it
became very quickly after he did that uh
especially after this school shooting
but she she it almost seems like she
rushed home
um to take this picture with her
children in front of a cr which i don't
understand what guns
because if you read here it says the
beau bert's have your six at rep thomas
massey so she's she's publicly not like
in a private text or something
she's publicly sending him this and all
not only that she says no spare ammo for
you though um almost like a thin veiled
uh
wink wink threat
kind of thing right yeah
i mean also notice that she did this
from her personal account you know so
again i think we had a conversation on
right out of the week where we talked
about this which is like using personal
versus your
uh
your
government
twitter account
and censorship and what you can and
can't say but right well and and because
paul gozar did it with the video where
he was you know it was an anime kind of
thing where he was chopping off
uh uh someone i think it was aoc and
stabbing joe biden or something like
that right um he put it on his actual
official account twitter didn't pull it
down because of that i think and then
she actually put up her apology to omar
which was last week when she was
actually the bo she was the bone end of
the week last weekend not for this
not for this but the same type violent
thin veiled threats that she was doing
when she was basically calling well not
basically she was outright calling oh
representative omar a terrorist by
saying she was you know jihad squad um
pointing out that she was a muslim and
basically
uh without saying it in so many words
that muslims are terrorist types right
[ __ ]
yeah she's really doubling down on uh on
being a shitty human being and the thing
is here is you know she says like we
know we got your back or whatever
right
uh
i'm i'm gonna i'm just gonna put this
out there i
and i'm sure other people did too i
called the colorado
child protective services the child
abuse and neglect hotline i left a tip
because i was like
look at this
yeah like this is dangerous like shannon
watts tweeted she pointed out that not
only not only are these children holding
holding these weapons these underage
children holding these weapons
but uh
also the the other crazy part about this
is that there is domestic violence
history in this house and now and the
statistics show
that when you have when you have
domestic violence inside the house like
that um and you have weapons inside the
house um it is it is very likely that
someone is going to be hurt by those
weapons in that household uh more it's
just a higher statistic possibility well
especially when
you know she's publicly stated that she
keeps them
uh
she said they she keeps them upstairs
right
yeah she's also yeah shannon also
brought that up where she is she is
jokingly
well and again i who knows what's real
and what's
what's not with lauren bobert it is i
mean like the elevator story about omar
you know you could tell all that shit's
made up right because she changed the
story over time it was just it was just
to joke around with her constituents to
give the thin veiled racism and bigotry
of jihad squad towards representative
omar is what she was doing but yeah the
the really um she joked about not having
them secure because oh uh and i think
this was back during the 2020 campaign
when joe biden was talking about gun
control um and i believe he said
something about going up the stairs or
something like that
i don't i don't remember exactly she may
have made a joke i don't know i could be
making this up but i wouldn't be
surprised if they said something like
this
like
because joe biden is in the basement he
can't get the guns that are upstairs
that yeah that's that's what it was i
think yeah and she said i don't ha my
guns aren't upstairs and she basically
made the joke uh and i think it was a
joke and who knows if it's if what she
is saying is actually real in its
projection because most things are
projection with these people um it it
she was making the joke that they are
not secure meaning they're
they're not they're not safe which is a
problem which would also show you that
it's like okay
i feel like there's an oxymoron when you
say like a safe gun owner is also a
republican you know right like this
exactly just don't match up no well i
mean they haven't for a long time they
haven't for a long time exactly and
that's why the majority of the country
wants gun safety
and i i believe that this is more of a
of a broader culture than just gun
culture because uh we see
uh this uh patriot front is that what
it's called that is that yeah because we
talked about it on bonehead of the week
now on this patreon the uh cosplaying in
cells yeah let's uh let's see this uh
here's the uh the u-haul picture that
you
that you posted on twitter um with the
uh cosplay incels on the side of the
u-haul truck of course you know it's uh
um
it's a shame because they you know if
they would have marched if they would be
allowed to carry these type of weapons
that these people
are bragging about and posting their
christmas pictures on washington dc they
certainly would have marched with those
weapons oh definitely yeah i mean they
had their you know their little plastic
shields and their little upside down
flags um but this is all part of this
same culture this
white nationalist q anon trump humping
cult type culture
where they're posting cause i'm i'm not
actually uh i actually don't think that
we should uh because we've had a
semi-automatic rifle ban in this country
i i don't know that we have to take it
that far i mean we're probably going to
have to with these morons but i don't
think we'd actually have to take it that
far we just make it a higher regulation
to actually own some of those type of
weapons um it's my opinion
and
yeah and that's that i think it was
when obama was leaving office in in 2016
uh he went on
what i was like the
what i would call
the uncensored obama like he had nothing
there was nothing really like right he
could do no re-election no nothing right
right so he was doing a bunch of town
halls and i think there's a it was a pbs
town hall um right exactly and he and
that topic came up right because
someone's like you want to come take
away our guns you know and he's like no
i don't want to take away guns we we do
not want to take away your guns like we
you know we
uh
we follow the second amendment right but
with anything it needs to be regulated
right right
then he's like what happened with the
seat belts right in the car industry
like you wouldn't give your you know in
order to drive you have to give your
information you have to have a card and
all this other stuff as opposed to like
you know getting a car illegally driving
illegally without a permit without
registration without insurance like
whatever it is
you know i mean most people have to take
a [ __ ] piss test to get a job
right exactly and i think at the end of
the day like if you were to it's i don't
know why these people are so up in arms
like um
they're leaning so heavily
on the second amendment that it's like
it is the word of god
but again it's it's this it's this take
pictures in front of a christmas tree
[ __ ] right i mean and that's the answer
that's the reason why i like i'm sure
others as well i was like this is
[ __ ] ridiculous
this is insane i was like whether the
kids wanted to take this photo or not
using them as a political prop for
something like this with that issue and
the way that she did was right
and here's the thing then you then you
have people like uh politico who are
like
won't really report on it but then
they'll do all the reporting on
uh
uh harris not being
into bluetooth devices for security
reasons obviously right it's ridiculous
it's just great stories
yeah
it's ridiculous so so speaking of massey
here's the uh bonehead of the week who
will it be marjorie taylor green louie
gohmert and thomas massey of course we
didn't get to these other two boneheads
because there's plenty of news about
them but we didn't get to them today but
uh go vote for bonehead of the week you
can go to the podcast page at tony
michael's pod
and go vote there for bone end of the
week and we will do another
episode of uh bonehead of the week next
this weekend um we'll post it and you
can watch that there of whoever wins
the bone of the week you know the other
story that that we didn't get to today
which i'm kind of disappointed is the uh
the fox news christmas
tree did you see this yeah i i tweeted
about it if you want to pull it up
really quick uh let let's see let's see
if we can find uh yeah anything let's
see if we can find um
your um are you talking about the the
the video that you did the quick little
video
yeah i uh
yeah
there it is
there it is let's let's see if we can
share this real quick uh tell us about
the video here while i'm pulling it up
so last night uh
it on twitter this video showed up from
because it was pulled from the citizen
app but uh all of a sudden
the yeah it's not gonna play my my
chrome is not it's not operating sorry
but go ahead
the fox christmas tree outside of their
uh
their news building was set on fire
and
i i i don't you know
uh
a lot of i've heard a lot of good jokes
you know people saying like they're
burning bush and people's all right how
like satan was coming back and how was
the end of days and this is this is what
you get for uh
for wanting to have a war on christmas
right or are the countries on fire so
it's kind of like right and it's because
of fox that's kind of like this metaphor
right exactly and so anyway last night
this huge ass tree gets set on fire
which i was also thinking about this
morning
and i was like oh well you know
uh
you know certain climates and
temperatures and whatnot easily to
to to cause fires like there's a little
bit of a climate crisis going on you
know it's dry probably not watering it
it's more flammable right but yeah this
tree went up in in flames and smoke and
was just like billowing black smoke
which even more of like symbolism
a fox
for fox news it's just billowing out at
night like there's some like gotta call
like ghostbusters to get whatever this
is or like a priest to exercise
this tree
but uh i saw i think i saw someone else
that was like even the tree wanted out
you know oh hell yeah why they i mean
they they they've had enough right the
trees yeah they're like we're we're done
stop stop uh
stop me trying to make us like the guns
and are in those kids a political prop
right exactly
right or your war on christmas or
whatever the [ __ ] this this cultish type
[ __ ] that they and and by the way our
interview coming up next right after
this next break uh is fantastic and we
talk a lot about the cult and this
michael flynn stuff and how all this and
i'm so glad
that that heidi came on um heidi kuda of
radicalized podcast uh is coming up
after the break but this is such a good
interview we recorded it several days
ago um so you're going to see me and
gabe and different outfits but uh so
it's kind of weird but but but we did
record it a couple days ago but we
really thank heidi for coming on and and
dropping the knowledge that she drops um
and uh it's it's too bad that we didn't
get to talk about the uh the cult
symbolism of the burning christmas tree
in the fox news plaza yeah
i'm sure yeah if anyone wants to find it
go for it it's on twitter uh yeah right
it is yes
and oh yeah
the whole thread is fantastic there's
yeah there's plenty of good stuff in
that in the in the fox i think it's fox
news christmas is the thread that you
wanna you wanna yeah search it fox news
christmas is that thread and that that's
where you'll spend at least 30 minutes
to an hour laughing your [ __ ] ass off
so go check it out yeah and also the uh
the fox news
their response to what happened is oh
tell me about that tell me about that so
you know basically they they've made it
all they're like you know fox and
friends and and a few others have like
fox business and they've all made it
they're like number one story about how
you know this is this is the problem
with america and this is the crime we
gotta get you know oh yeah this is the
megan mccain thing right that yeah we're
comparing it to the january 6
insurrection right but i saw someone
point out that within the within two
tweets of each like within one tweet of
each other like back to back megan
mccain went from
uh
the party is
is crazy to
uh
[Music]
to yes blaming or or
uh being upset about
january 6 and everyone else freaking out
about the tree or vice versa it's like a
whole
again it's it's just like the
projectionism like the projecting and
also the simple uh
i hear i hear a fire truck in the
background maybe you need to go check on
your christmas tree uh why we're why
we're at yeah but but st st stay with us
gabe go check your christmas tree stay
with us uh we'll be back with the
interview uh right after this break
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babble
maggot edition makes it really easy to
learn and there's lots of lessons to
choose from like subtly racist to
full-blown white supremacists the first
lesson began with learning simple
phrases and soon i was putting those
words and phrases into a conversation
each lesson takes about 10 to 15 minutes
to complete and they're all really
different which keeps things interesting
the app is really smart it actually
keeps track of the word that i'm
struggling with i chose babble mag
edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now i can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new maga skills with my in-laws all
lives matter
[Music]
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the tony michaels
podcast we have our special guest today
heidi kuda an investigative journalist
she's got a huge resume but we're just
going to stick with investigative
journalists right now because we have a
ton of questions uh she's a co-host of
the radicalized podcast and i'm so
excited to have her thank you heidi for
being here on the show today we have so
many questions for you including some
trivia questions so are you ready are
you ready for all these questions that
we have for you today yes but
standardized tests is not my forte so
we'll see
well we promise there's no prizes and no
no scores um we just we want to have a
little fun with the trivia right i do
want to start by asking you about your
podcast because you're a co-host you
have other other people on this podcast
called radicalized so tell us a little
bit about your podcast and what that
piece of content is and why you guys are
doing that right on well first of all i
want to thank you so much for inviting
me on your show i'm a big believer in uh
building bridges and tribes and
communities who are in this fight for
essentially the soul of democracy uh
it's a global fight
um i put together radicalized with jim
stewartson
high fidelity and sean connor
because they're not only three of the
smartest
uh people
i know and people in this battle
they're also three of the coolest people
i know and so
we form like an incredible alchemy but
two of the guys
jim and hi-fi were really pivotal in
exposing and essentially shutting down
what folks call cue and on um
and so i knew that they both were
incredible sources of knowledge but also
i've been i was in broadcast news for
many decades and uh
i have post traumatic news syndrome i
can't go and lurk in these horrible
places it sounds funny right no no i i i
can't i totally get it i i can't i i i
follow jim and uh other accounts like
patriot takes and some of the others
that that make sure that people get to
see what these
what these wackadoos are talking about
in some of these places yeah and it's
sometimes it's almost hard just to watch
some of those feeds and to see what
they're saying so yes so you know jim
and hi-fi and some of the colleagues
that they work with
have decided for the greater good to
immerse themselves in these worlds with
all of this
trauma
trigger [ __ ]
uh and they bring us the news from the
trenches and it's incredibly vital
um that not only
that they're doing the work but also
that we're able then to bring it to
our platform radicalized podcast um
which in
now you know we're going into our uh
third or fourth week it's already been
creating uh the stir that we hope to
create and we're getting allies from all
over
the world reaching out saying how can i
help and that was really the goal
because we know we've lost a chunk of
the population through many democratic
countries and that's not by uh accident
so i'm all about holding the line and
quite frankly it's like what's the team
you want to go to war with i want to go
to war with jim hi-fi and sean conner
right those guys got my back and ours i
mean i i think i think you're right with
like this q and on stuff and pockets of
the world i think that's kind of what
you're saying there
um i've had some of my you know and i've
talked about it on my show i've had some
of my family members follow this q anon
type stuff and they not even know that
it's really queuing on right through
facebook and some of these other social
media platforms they've they fall prey
to some of these disinformation or
misinformation disinformation campaigns
right um
so here's what i think cue how it kind
of started and maybe you can correct me
um on how some of this stuff is since
you guys are really diving deep into
this
so i remember charlottesville on the
alt-right um
came to charlottesville and we remember
the torches and all these kind of
in-cell white
dudes who were part of like gamergate
kind of thing right um
and it it did the neo-nazi thing didn't
sell very well right then the alt-right
thing didn't sell in the religious
religious evangelical community as much
and i think really when the q anon
really started taking hold in this
evangelical community
the the white supremacists the neo-nazis
the fascists were like hey
we've got this great opportunity we can
run with some of this q and stuff and
really
embed our ideas
into this q anon stuff because q anon
really isn't like one conspiracy theory
it's like all of them in one big soup
right or am i completely wrong about all
of that you tell me you
know you know jim
jim and hi-fi i defer to as the experts
on this and there's many different
people that i've interviewed who really
are incredible researchers and ocean
guys and there's a debate on the origins
you know i i defer to
jim which really
he's been working very hard to expose
mike general mike flynn's role in this
um and there's a historical precedent
for
generals like him who are disgruntled
who were fired uh who think they know
better
um who
clearly have some sort of messiah you
know messiah complex but
totally with
whichever whichever way
you know whatever your investigation
shows whichever way you look at it
doesn't really matter
i mean it does matter ultimately once
justice comes in but
we have a mass psychosis going on these
people are victims of a psychological
attack i believe it's by design i
believe that uh somebody like flynn who
has expertise in psychological
operations knows exactly what he's doing
some people say oh he's just going where
the money is you know russia pays him
turkey pays him whatever i think
somewhere along the line
something truly happened to him at one
point if you recall in the mueller
report
when he was you know indicted for lying
to the you know uh fbi and then he pled
guilty somewhere in that period of time
he emerges with i think sydney powell as
his lawyer
says that he was you know coerced into
into pleading guilty
perhaps there's some nefarious
players involved that may have made him
change his mind from cooperating but
whatever happened
uh this horrible
um
psychological attack has
permeated the country and unfortunately
it's going global and when you say that
it's not just one thing you're
absolutely right it's many things and
a guess that we're going to have a week
from tomorrow
uh dr charles uh creel and kat gellen
they did the film people you may know
they also have a film called disinformed
which shows the
the attacks never stop there's no rear
areas and they show the infiltration of
this type of
conspirator conspiratorial thinking
uh in the wellness community
so yoga moms are being impacted by
disinformation and they're doing it much
like with q and on
by having these trauma videos
using
doctored videos of little white children
who look like they're abused it looks
like a crt voodoo type stuff that's
starting to sprout up everywhere sure
same kind of sure
it doesn't matter whether it's crt
anti-vaxx school board menace jfk stuff
i mean it just it you know um and the
reason why i say like the conspiracy
theory soup
is because
um like sovereign citizen stuff started
to show up in this q anon when they were
talking about how trump was going to
take over as the 19th president back in
march that's some kind of sovereign
citizen type [ __ ] right um you know a
lot of these other conspiracy theories
that have never really
coupled with any other conspiracy theory
start to
leak into the soup
and i think it's because these people
who are trying to perpetrate this
misinformation are like let's just see
what we can actually like how far are
the bounds like how far can we take this
like jim actually did and i have it here
i want to show this clip jim did a video
of a a woman who was a leader of a cult
in the 1980s and he compared it to
almost a seance or something that mike
flynn was
duping it it felt like to me and i'll
show the clip here but it felt like to
me he was mike flynn is duping these
people inside of this church yeah to
repeat this thing they don't know what
they're repeating but because he's
saying it it sounds good and now they're
almost it almost feels like
in the original video
she is trying to manipulate people
and in the mike flynn part of the video
he has totally
got them exactly where he wants them to
repeat this nonsense that they have no
idea what it is they'll just repeat
everything he says because he's testing
them almost i am so excited that you're
choosing that video because i got a
couple things to say about that awesome
well let's watch it and then we'll talk
about it on the other side mighty i am
presence i am hero god and i am the
instrument of those sevenfold rays and
archangels we are your instrument of
those sevenfold rays and all your
archangels all of them and i will not
retreat i will take my stand i will not
fear to speak and i will be the
instrument of god's will whatever it is
we will not retreat
we will not retreat
we will stand our ground
we'll we will not fear to speak
we will be the instrument of your will
whatever it is
here i am so help me god in the name of
archangel michael and his legions i
am reborn and i shall remain reborn and
i shall not be enslaved by any foe
within or without
[Applause]
in your name
and the name of your legions
we are freeborn
and we shall remain freeborn
and we shall not be enslaved
by any foe
within or without
so help me god
god bless you god bless america thank
you very much
so there is so much craziness yeah
unpack from that video yeah i'll let you
start since you said you have some
things you'd like to say about it i do
so
what you just saw was general mike flynn
uh jumped the shark
he went a little bit
i love it i love it he went a little too
far with that one gentlemen and let me
explain so
jim stewartson worked very hard
when he heard
flynn
recite that cultish prayer he was like
what the [ __ ] is this
it is [ __ ] nuts he works very very
hard and low
he finds
uh elizabeth claire prophet a doomsday
cult leader had originally penned
that uh prayer
and uh we subsequent we subsequently
became friends
jim initially became friends with her
son
and he filled us in on a lot of the
history wait the prop prophet son yeah
yeah which you guys would love him you
should have him on the show his name is
that's great yeah his name is sean
prophet he was kind of groomed to take
over
this doomsday cult
as they normally do right right that's
what i want to do
like what's the one with the bullet
crown that's one they passed on to
generations oh there's another cult that
the one that trump did a video sean moon
you're talking about it yeah sean moon
yeah and so just because you happen to
segway over to the to the moonies
know that grift is always behind this
right so so what you see
is not really what's there what's
usually there is somebody with a history
of corruption fraud felony indictments
and jail time that's that's uh the the
mooney's origin
uh that's pretty much any of these folks
and so her son actually
had a real awakening
when the grift and the corruption within
uh his mother's cult was exposed they
were doing some red dawn doomsday thing
i think in lake montana somewhere uh
preparing the 80s preparing for the
apocalypse but but they were doing it by
buying
weapons illegally through somebody
else's name and all kinds of chicanery
and he all of a sudden was like wait a
minute
this [ __ ] is really toxic and illegal
and he got out and he's been
uh he's been basically you know uh kind
of atoning and telling his story
you know it's hard it's his mother um
perhaps she might have believed it but
so what happened so because it's like an
archangel michael thing i don't know who
in mike flynn's camp gets the idea that
it would be good to recite this cult
doomsday prayer in a christmas church
do you think that
he knows the like so whoever in the camp
says hey give this speech very impactful
powerful i mean you could obviously like
when it's delivered not you know with a
hand to the head and like you're doing a
seance almost yeah it sounds that sounds
crazy but when you're on stage and
you're just kind of delivering like line
by line doesn't sound so crazy but i do
wonder
and maybe you know um
so when whoever in the camp comes from
and says hey give this speech right do
you think he knows the backstory to it
or do you think that he's just told this
is great and he's like yeah this sounds
great to me let's do it
he is the messiah mike flynn so the
messiah
here's another way to
engage and
rapture and bring people to him so when
he runs for president he has this cult
already for me oh my [ __ ] god i
like hearing that well
you know
oh my god you talking about the shame
the shame has been long since gone if
you see any of the the home videos that
he makes
uh in the backyard
you see the twitching but you see the
twitching like you know you can actually
see like the kind of the aliens and the
demons coming out of the eyes now
because they can't contain just how much
sickness soul sickness lurks in them
trump will run for president uh from
prison if he has to
uh and you know flynn is actually uh you
know trying to
uh build this cult that will empower him
to bring on whatever
rapture he's trying to bring on and and
for whoever is behind the uh checks that
i'm sure he's cashing we already know of
checks that he physically cashed from
you know russia and other uh places that
are actually very vested in the fossil
fuel industry and as i'm sure you guys
know
so much of the chicanery we see is
financed by
dark money organizations often
affiliated with the council for national
policy they have a lot of fossil fuel
money they don't care about the end of
times they just want to continue to prop
up the industry that supports places
like russia and parts of the middle east
so they can stave off the inevitable
renewables future that's kind of a high
concept on a lot of this and so whether
or not mike flynn
knows what the [ __ ] he's doing when he
recites that doomsday cult prayer in a
christian church
what happened thanks to my co-host and
our friend jim stewartson
is it
became exposed
it was it was it was a story that they
couldn't do damage control on through
our dear friend jenny cohen she coined
satan gate and suddenly there's a
division
within
the uh flynn world and why that's
important is you guys probably have been
at this long enough to know that
uh the gop and the extreme right they
stick together
during the worst of times oh my god do
they yeah even with a a reality tv
douchebag who launders money for
allegedly why i mean i saw this you saw
this this week with this maxwell trial
where he wished her well back when he
was president there's people coming out
and defending her now it's just like
because of some of the testimony that's
happening um you see splits in that so
so explain the split explain why
this this this investigative where they
pinned these two things together and
discovered okay why did this split the q
a why did this split why did this cause
so much strife so
okay so there's a lot of theater craft
always involved so i'm suspicious i'm
looking around dark corners all the time
going is this real is this not real
jim
believes that this is absolutely a real
division because at some point
christians
who really do believe in their christ
right even though
many of the churchy people are being
sold a very toxic version of
christianity
that doomsday cult when dissected
is about
multiple christs and things that at
their core it's essentially satanic
right so that's why when our friend
jenny jumped it stepped at satan gate it
created such a stir and uh you had
people like ellen wood who is really not
sort of the paragon of virtue
but he publicly condemned it as did
others and so
i find it very refreshing to know that
there are wedges that can be put in
between this this kind of uh
i don't know wall of grifters
uh and and one thing i do want to say is
that the the person who did the most
work on showing the infiltration of
oligarch cash into the gop
is a professor at the university of
dallas named ruth c may
she did a very iconic piece
for the dallas morning news where she
showed the money infiltration and just
how
core members
of the gop
were infected with russian money
and she says that evil people
eventually devour themselves right
exactly they have to don't they i think
that's what we're seeing right here at
the beginning of the cannibalization it
is my hope so
go ahead yeah no i was gonna say i think
that's uh you know
i think with all these things you find
there's a level of hubris right like i
can't fall you know or yeah you've got
icarus right and he flies too close to
the sun brilliant but i think that i
that idea of like
they think uh
they cannot do no wrong right they they
like you said they built up this
following they have this cult
messiah
and i think for many of them they're
like
you know [ __ ] hits me and it just
brushes right off right and i think at a
certain point that level of hubris and
egotistical
mania just overwhelms and
does end up being the the downfall
of what they
built this this you know um
facade to be
a hundred percent correct and i'm just
trying to pull up the gandhi line
um because it's absolute freaking lutely
true
all throughout history there have been
tyrants and murderers and for a time
they seem invincible but in the end they
always fall always wouldn't it be nice
for michael flynn who has perpetuated so
much harm
into the collective psyche of our
country wouldn't it be incredible if he
fell before he gained any more power
absolutely
well let's keep going with your podcast
and keep projecting this message because
i believe i believe that um when you
talk about because i think what you're
saying is is that
when evangelicals um
were
shown that hey they're they're duping
you with this crazy ass [ __ ] just to
grift you um i think that really that
really strikes a real hard nerve with
some evangelical christians like you say
people who actually believe some of the
stuff they're saying not just not just
part of the grift um but i also have
seen
the january 6 select because i think the
truth is the thing that tears these
things down just like jim exposing the
truth of what this speech was and what
this seance type prayer
oath whatever the hell mike flynn was
trying to convey on stage and dupe the
because i think he was duping those
people in that room and saying that
thing they were just following what he
was going to do whatever he could have
said he could have said cheetos are
great and coca-cola sucks and they would
have repeated it
i'm dead serious i know you are now now
i think also the truth because jim
exposing the truth of what mike flynn
did there uh is ultimately the thing
that tears these things apart and also
that is why they are fighting so hard
not to testify they're willing to go to
criminal criminal charges in federal
court yeah on contempt because i believe
you see alex jones
uh yelling and screaming on his show
about this uh this maxwell testimony
which i don't actually think alex jones
is losing his mind about that as much as
he is trying to tear apart this this
fabric because alex jones sees this
going in a completely wild direction
that is not good for him you see roger
stone and lynn wood uh
tucker carlson all these people just
start to
like you said earlier devour each other
and i believe that is what is happening
is
um and i think that's why the select
committee is as much as america wants
this thing to happen really fast
the design is to slow leak this thing so
they do tear each other apart because if
they just drop all this stuff at once
they can claim oh that's all that's all
fake news but if it's little by little
by little it really tears them apart so
do you see
do you see that that
that the january 6 select committee um
not only to uncover maybe federal crimes
here but also to undo some of this
psyche stuff that you were talking about
this reprogramming that they're trying
to do of america and other parts of the
world i think that
well that's a two-part question i'll do
my best to answer it sure um i think
that the d
in 2018 i wrote an article about the d
naught
uh in world war ii they did a
denotification
attempt the allies to try to denaxify
people and it was so vast they sort of
just kind of gave up so i think that a d
trumpification will take place in
america over time
i like the freeze i like the freeze
thank you so i did this whole thing
where i interviewed some really
incredible experts uh in psychology and
political uh science as well as uh you
know white-collar crime lawyers and how
do we de-trumpify well
after looking at everything i realize
that
we just have to say goodbye to a portion
of our populists for the moment those
people are still there they're going to
pop back out probably on their own time
and 10 years from now they'll probably
never admit to having voted for trump
because by then so much will be revealed
so it's very very important that we hold
the line
on the majority and the same majority
because as i'm sure you know in your own
life we're already getting people picked
off through like i was saying through
you know the wellness communities as
well oh yeah yeah and all of that
absolutely they're believing this q and
on stuff without knowing that's exactly
what's exactly right so we have to
continually hold the line now in order
to really make a dent a couple things
have to happen
uh uh influence war has to be declared
that we're going through it executive
orders need to be signed the government
has to get behind
major major uh disinformation
you know um just basically to to build
up not so much an industry around it but
in sweden and in finland and in estonia
they have the government working with um
tech to expose the influence campaigns
and what propaganda looks like and they
have made huge inroads so you really
can't pull the same [ __ ] that's being
pulled here in denmark sweden finland
and estonia because they have taken
their population they said this is
what's happening this is what to be on
the lookout for and unfortunately right
now it's been left up to citizen
activists to deliver that message and
i'm working with people this weekend
actually on putting together a document
that basically says if you think that
you're you might be the victim of you
know um kind of mind alteration here are
some questions to ask yourselves so
we're sort of all kind of doing it
ourselves now back to your
january sixth question i had i had a
moment uh over the last couple of days
when i was studying um
fascism through the expert on italian
fascism that offers like a kind of a a
collection of people that come together
every friday to talk about this stuff
there was a moment when i looked at who
was being subpoenaed
right and i realized that the mob roll
up that we've been praying for since
2019 since the mueller report came out i
wanted the people who actually read it
and you could see that they had done a
pretty thorough job of showing what what
really was uh happening and how we were
infiltrated and of course the
indictments of the russian troll farm
also revealed that and the midterm
indictments all this [ __ ] gets papered
over right but those things really
happened
so that mob roll up that we've all hoped
would come
and result in perp walks
mass perp walks i am hopeful that 2022
is that year and it's gonna go one way
or the other either either the cult's
gonna see
these folks in orange jumpsuits without
toupees
uh and without their lips
i'm serious
i know you are that's the best part i'm
so serious
the second the second the second the
cult sees
trump as he really is which is which is
an elderly
you know
baldwin
uh
they will with bad lighting and
everything they will realize they've
been conned and when that happens i do
hope
that we see uh you know millions of
people who are like ex-smokers where
they really [ __ ] hate cigarettes
i think there's a very good chance that
that will happen now it does require our
justice system to still work
i think that there is evidence that it
still can work i think that there is
clearly a bit of a lack of will to see
an american president go to
jail but not this one this one has
committed so many crimes as well as
no i was going to say which goes to the
theme of your show which is very near
and dear to me my first book was with a
rapper actor named ice t
and he taught me the beauty of you know
uh [ __ ] you and [ __ ] you too
and so and so just the [ __ ] theme is
very important to me
very very near and dear to my heart we
strive to make sure that that is out
front and part part of our message is
[ __ ] them i want you to say it a couple
times say say [ __ ] embarrass so we can
cut it in
uh [ __ ] em
yes
so gay were you are you gonna ask uh
yeah so so i think you know
uh a lot of the ways that i kind of um
digest this
insane world is through satire and
obviously satire has like in itself kind
of jumped a shark because now every day
you're like oh what was you know i would
normally heighten this to a 10 or 11 and
now the base level of reality is like a
17 and i've you know heard and
and just the other day you know i was
reading the article about the people who
were eating dirt right for uh to treat
covet yeah
and i'm like oh my god i cannot believe
we live in a reality where people are
literally
wait wait wait wait what did you just
say they're doing what now they're
they're eating dirt it's no yeah i
thought yeah i thought in the dm you
were talking about taking a dirt nap
like they were dying so they were you
know i mean yeah eventually sure the
people that are thinking they could just
like beat covet will you know do their
own research wait a second i'm lost i'm
lost here the last thing i heard was is
you were supposed to bathe in borax to
shed the vaccine yeah see this is this
is the trouble with it don't you think
heidi like they they move the target so
fast sometimes and that's kind of the
intent isn't it yeah well so so we live
in a 24-hour news cycle of [ __ ] and a
24-hour news cycle of pain it didn't
used to be like that
in order for the minority party which is
you know my colleagues call it a death
cult and i'm in agreement of that um in
order for them to continue to stay in
the headlines and in front of the
headlines
they share these talking points and i'm
sure
every week someone's like okay man
you're gonna say this you're gonna say
that right you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna piss off the smart people
so the smart people just play
whack-a-mole the whole time they just
they're just like that's not true that's
not true so lying is the message right
right lying is the message when you say
all those lies and then the media
parrots those lies
all those lies enter the collective
psyche and people start to not know
what's real and what's not and it's a
the the theater of fog it's a theater
craft it's the fog of unknowability
these are all
cyber war
uh mind uh propaganda war this is all
mind [ __ ] so
so
many of these talking points originate
with people who are affiliated with the
council for national policy
and that's when you that's when you see
all of a sudden the weird [ __ ] happening
in the school boards the weird [ __ ]
happening with doctors who have harvard
pedigrees talking about anti-vex the
weird [ __ ] happening when the oath
keepers show up you know armed to
protest masks at a school board meeting
all this weird [ __ ] this is not stuff
that's free or or this information about
eating dirt so i i haven't been part of
the collective what did you call it the
collective
[ __ ] yeah the collective mind i have
been part of this collective mindfuckery
so i i really i want to clown these
people about eating dirt because i used
to call them paste eaters but they
stopped doing that right yeah clowned
them enough that they stopped eating the
paste you know they started to go oh no
i'm getting it the ivermectin from a
doctor so tell me gabe what is this
eating dirt thing yeah so it's called
magic dirt and
it's from a company that's called black
and i'm bringing the article right now
like they're showing them dirt yeah so
black oxygen organics aka
uh it became a sudden hit in the fringe
world of alternative medicines and
supplements where a bag of dirt can go
for a hundred and ten dollars well [ __ ]
i'm gonna start bagging it up and i'm
gonna call mine black magic dirt or
something let me let me tell you
something this is the same [ __ ] that you
were talking about earlier heidi where
they they they take this wellness thing
and they see people who are desperate
because i believe that's what a lot of
the because a lot of these anti-vaxxers
have went from being anti-masters to
anti-vaxxers now they're anti-testers
like they won't even take a [ __ ] test
yeah holy [ __ ] you people
where
eventually you're gonna have to come to
uh uh to an evolution of the truth here
it's not
it there's gonna be a brick wall that
they're gonna hit when you're talking
about like uh people coming to
back to reality right they're like just
landing back onto earth
and understanding that they were just
duped conned whatever you want to call
it for the last
five or so years yeah um
or longer you know but uh
i
i have a hard time
[Music]
for many of the reasons including this
dirt story
uh
accepting the fact that people
who were unable
to
see the writing on the wall or unable to
see past the grift or what have you
are are going to come back to reality i
feel like
there might be some here and there but
i've i've also lost the patience and i'm
just like [ __ ] them i don't really care
anymore i've had i i've had patience
during the pandemic for 18 plus months
for you guys to get your [ __ ] together
and you
every point you move it to say oh i cut
open my mask and there was a [ __ ] sim
card in there like that was one thing
because people thought there was 5g
chips or like i
or
uh bill gates wants to track you it's
like i don't think he really gives a
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] you're doing right
they they they're like so far out there
that i have this
inability to
accept that they will come back and
again i don't really care now because
i've lost my patience and i think many
people have as well
but
i don't even i don't even know what that
world looks like even how to get them
back and i know that you talked about
like you know uh you know
disinformation campaigns to to
to reveal those things but yeah i'm just
like i can't even imagine a world now
where someone can go from i'm gonna eat
dirt to treat covid back to hey let's go
back to a civilized like functioning
household right
so they're running out of plot lines
okay because if they're on to the magic
dirt you already know that they're
scraping the bottom right
so i thought the ivormectin was bad but
here here we are here we go again you
know uh one one of the investigations i
did with sean conner our art director
and uh you know uh co-producer on our
show he's real genius he does the music
and everything he has a litigation
support firm and so
he profiled this guy we we worked on it
together uh this guy todd calendar who
is a anti-vaxxed lawyer who has an
anti-vac site where he shills all this
alternative crap the site is illegally
registered to some oklahoma native
american tribe who's never heard of him
he has he lives in the bahamas
all his shell companies are registered
to the most elite
area in moscow
where stalin lives exactly and he's got
family members he's virulently
anti-vaxxed nanoparticle guy nuremborg
trial guy
uh and his family members actually own a
anti-vaxx uh i own a vaccine technology
company yeah of course they do there's
so much to unpack there but
follow the money focus on the grift
right so
uh so when you look at some of the
anti-vaxx movement and who's paying for
it you find shadowy packs that are
funded by robert mercer
freaking tax dead bait deadbeat weirdo
who you probably know
how how is trump president and robert
mercer comes up right well what's what's
incredible is that when you peel it back
i'm a follow the money girl that's what
i do when you peel it back you're like
oh here's the investigative journal
robert mercer's cash went to anti-facts
it went to trying to prop the doctor
atlas up it went to prop up these
alternative medications uh and they're
making all
kinds of money on it it's just a modern
snake oil like the magic dirt is just
nothing more than snake oil
but so much of what we're looking at is
a group of people who still want their
team to win
uh everything that they're looking at at
facebook is being marketed and designed
to [ __ ] with their minds the trauma
videos are adjacent to that so we've
lost them temporarily but
the reason that we talked about radical
empathy on our last show is because gabe
these techniques these psychological
operations are designed to make you hate
these people and want to go to war with
them because they're so [ __ ] right
right that is not good for us the
continuing divide is not good for us
it's great for russia
it's great for our enemies it's great
for mike flynn it's not for trumpism
it's great for trumpism it's not good
for us so
somehow we gotta reach into some sort of
resources that are not always easy to
find and i fail at this quite frequently
i try not to but i do still cut people
out of my life who call me a communist
because that's really dumb uh but
but it's designed to make us hate each
other and want to bring baseball bats
and we have to try very hard to practice
the yes and
uh
motif like so give us an example
someone says some crazy [ __ ] about the
satanic pedophile ring run by hillary
clinton yes and instead you say yeah and
and you go on and drop some knowledge
not some hard facts coming at him you
haven't told them hey you freaking
idiot you know
uh because they if you facts are
designed to make them clench up and go
enemy enemy enemy alert they're not
going to go oh my gosh you're so right
no
they they've been brave right
they've been brainwashed nobody
brainwashes themselves we have to view
them as victims right uh and we just
have to keep on holding the line on
those we haven't lost yet so 2022
is going to go one of two ways
either all of the [ __ ] that's been
bought and paid for
by the
dominionists and the fossil fuel
fascists who [ __ ] with our election
systems are going to result in extreme
right wing domination of our country
or
we're going to see that mob roll up perp
walks we're going to activate the
democratic base and we're going to crush
pro-democracy baby that's what i i'm
talking about
so so that leads me to my last thing and
then and then maybe we'll get to uh some
trivia here we'll ask some some really
hard-pressed questions um
let we'll have some fun can you send me
the answers in the chat
[Laughter]
no cheating no cheating okay so
so so this brings me to my last point
that i wanted to ask about because um
i think what you're saying is that that
it is going to take some time right and
we have to be patient with with these
folks that have actually been duped
because i i agree with a little bit what
you're saying a little bit with what
gabe's saying i think some of these
people are in a situation where
they're almost like well i'm not gonna
give up on this idea yet right i mean
like like i know it's crap i know i've
been duped but i'm not gonna give up yet
right because there still may be at the
end of the tunnel we still may be able
to to win right
but
but that goes back to fascism like you
said and fascism taking over because
that's the ultimate goal of the grift
right is to grift and to get fascism and
get power so they can keep on grifting
because i i believe that's why trump
wanted to remain president is to keep
he didn't actually want to be president
it was just keep grifting so my question
is
is that we can never kill this idea of
fascism right we can't kill an idea uh
in the short term maybe maybe long term
and generations beyond us will look back
and go fascism is just completely stupid
and it's not even a thing we should
consider
but how can we prevent it from grabbing
hold and becoming this religion that it
has become because that i think is the
most dangerous part about this is it's
not really an idea uh it is an idea but
it has started to become this religion
through q anon trumpism there's
different pockets around the world with
this anti-vaxx anti-mass stuff that it
has become a religion how do we prevent
that and how do we
can we undo it and is it the same as
just people going oh i wasn't duped like
a 1930s germany when people thought oh
my gosh this nazi thing was not so great
you know what what what how does that
look to you oh my god
thank you for asking something i know
the answer to
we'll count this as a trivia question
yeah yeah there you go we'll give you
points
so
there was never a time that the german
people woke up and said that there was
never time that the majority of the
german people woke up and voted for
hitler it did not happen they began the
autocratic capture of institutions
uh bit by bit
until one day people woke up and they
were under this rule of somebody that
the majority never voted for okay so one
way you prevent it is by continuing to
do your podcast it's important not every
not everybody can do everything but
everybody can do something so you're
doing your podcast and you're inviting
people on to talk about this stuff so go
you guys it's really [ __ ] important
number two
or three or four
uh
there is not an autocrat or a dictator
in the history of autocrating and
dictating
that did not come into power to hide
their own [ __ ] corruption so trump is
not and uh does not have an exemption to
that rule they come into power to hide
their corruption they come into power
doing tit for tat i'll do this for you
you do this for me you wonder why all
these people who seemed sane prior to
trump got behind him they all needed
favors if you google anybody in trump's
world uh
and you and you google the word fraud
right
there they are there's their history of
fraud their complaints their lawsuits
they're out of court settlements he's no
different he was less successful than
some of them because a he he despite how
hard he tried he couldn't keep the griff
up a second term he's gonna try again so
yeah he's still teaching he's still
committing a coup don't you think very
yes it's a slow slow moving coup one one
thing that you have to
that i had to wrap my head around i i'm
in the middle of reading a book called
they came from something awful it's very
important to show how trumpism is a
direct result out of the 4chans the guy
who wrote it had a father from
czechoslovakia that's where my dad was
born to my dad's from the german
community
but the story holds the same
his father ultimately escaped from the
iron curtain came to america and told
his son fascism never goes away it only
sleeps it will come back and so what we
are seeing is it coming back and that's
why we're seeing this as a
extreme right-wing global coup
all these people
from from russia who has a parasitic
leader who steals from the people to
give to himself and others from
the brazil's leader all these folks if
you look at hungary
belarus they're all empowered to hide
their corruption and they're white
knuckling it because they don't want to
lose power right we must know there are
more of us while we are still able to
think and speak for ourselves and freely
we must know there are more of us and we
can all do something
fascism just sleeps it never goes away
we have to stop the autocratic capture
we have to vote like our country and our
life and our children's lives depend on
it we have to ensure that the party as
imperfect as it is
democrats want to help people
overwhelmingly
the gop does not care if we die those
are the two choices that you have
autocracy democracy choose wisely
because you know
i think you have a kid right i've got
kids what the [ __ ] are we doing if we're
not fighting
that's it well and i i think the
pro-democracy message is a great message
and i want to thank you for the great
conversation i had so much fun listening
to all the knowledge that you're
dropping even though some of it is not
exactly what we want to hear we need to
hear this stuff we need to hear what the
truth is and how this thing is going to
unpack itself but before we go
before we go we want to play a little
game of trivia
all right this is the part of the show
where we're gonna play a little trivia
uh today's topic is random i've got
stuff all over the board so
how you guys do the rules is i'm going
to ask five questions each question is
worth one point the first one to
ring in or give a thumbs up uh uh
you will get a chance to answer the
question if you get it wrong your
opponent will have a shot at the point
and whoever has the most points after
five questions
wins
are you two ready i'm ready so question
number one napoleon bonaparte charles de
gaulle winston churchill and juan carlos
the first were all leaders from this
from countries on which continent a asia
b africa c south america or d europe
uh well um if i'm not mistaken gabe the
answer would be europe but i already
forgot which letter it was so i don't
know if i still get that one you're good
it's d
d europe okay good question number two
which was longest in miles a the oregon
trail or b
silk road or c they were the same length
okay so i have no idea but i'm gonna go
with the same length uh that is
incorrect
heidi oh i would think it was the silk
road that is correct
oregon trail was 2 000 miles and silk
road was 4 000 miles do you know how
roughly about how i know that
the crash course history
everything i know came from that green
fellow you know 10 minute history
lessons that's all i got the capacity
what is this what is this tell us about
this oh there's a amazing youtube guy uh
okay crash course history
and he gives all the historic
knowledge in 10-minute youtube it's
awesome uh animated tutorials and in
every episode there's something about
the mongols
[Laughter]
well you know you know so so i i was
gonna go with a with oregon trail
because i would have been wrong anyways
because there was this video or uh well
it was a video game it's like a computer
game you remember this computer game
oregon trail long long ago when they had
it on like the the six and a half floppy
or whatever it was
right and and uh you always i always got
diphtheria and died or something
i never i never made it to the end of
the organ trail or like we lost the
wheel in a river
and we couldn't
couldn't repair it so i was dead in the
water you know i never i never could win
the game because there was always
something that happened well i i figured
that was i i would play the game when i
was waiting for piano lessons for the
short period of time that i played the
piano uh when you're waiting for your
lesson you can hang out in like the
little playroom right and one of the
games on the computer obviously with the
big floppy was oregon trail and i would
play that
and also would never get it like get
through it long enough to actually get
somewhere but i would find myself like
oh you tried to cross this river and
your cattle like got swept away or
whatever it was
you're dead you're dead i always died i
always die
i feel like that was i don't know if you
could have ever really won that game it
was like every uh consolation prize was
uh some sort of disease or just like
famine or whatever you know
i did i didn't mean to get us off on the
oregon trail game but you know you know
that's okay that was fun i was just
wondering what consumption was everybody
used to diet consumption i don't know
what it is oh yes yes yes yes yes what
is
what is consumption i don't like on the
oregon trail i don't know
i i think that might be what we're dying
from today
this is consumption like we consume
consumed that's right we've done that
we're dying from consumption of the
24-hour new cycle issue that's right
that's right that's right it's just the
consumption of dirt you know yeah yeah
yeah the black magic dirt or whatever
those [ __ ] grifters
[Laughter]
all right
so question number three
which of the following bands
didn't or hasn't had a john in it a the
beatles b
queen
c the rolling stones or d led zeppelin
ah i'm just gonna go with c the rolling
stones but i could be wrong that is
correct
the beatles had john lennon of course
queen had john deacon and led zeppelin
had uh john paul jones okay well see i
wouldn't have gotten that one right
probably because the only one i knew was
the beatles because i i i like i like
music so when i hear music oh i know
this song but i don't know who wrote it
what year it was like none of that stays
put with me it's just the song that
stays put with me like even really
popular music yeah someone's like you
don't know who wrote this i'm like no i
i have no idea i know this song by heart
but i have no idea who wrote it who's
saying it i have no idea that's how i
that's how i feel like because i was uh
raised catholic so
whenever i go to friends weddings or
whatever and and we'll go to church
uh
for those
i
subconsciously remember every hymn psalm
prayer
like i don't even consciously do it it
just happens you just you know and then
like 10 seconds and i'm like oh [ __ ]
what oh my god i totally like i've said
it so many times as a kid it is just
burned into my memory i i i want you
guys to enjoy the gray matter well it
still functions and you still have it i
tried to recite i i had a terrible
thought yesterday and i expressed it and
then i felt really bad so i tried to
recite three hail marys today
and i and i couldn't i couldn't get
through i couldn't remember i got
through like the beginning and then i
was like oh [ __ ] did i know eric
yeah well maybe she'll pray for you to
remember her prayer you know
you know the best part is where i
believe
i believe all three of us were catholic
at some point in our lives yeah i said i
had to say a lot of [ __ ] hail mary
yeah
a lot of
ten
so i bullshitted the confessionals where
i would just come up with little minor
infractions you know
i'd never really say the devious stuff
that i really did just a little [ __ ]
right just the little [ __ ] yeah yeah i
have i have a good story about uh being
an altar boy and i promise it's not it's
not one that you you know oh i hope it's
not every convention
so the the best the best part about the
alter because there was uh there was a
lot of us uh as altar boys and they
would put um like when they would
schedule us they would put one of the
older boys with the younger boys right
so like one had been doing it for a long
time and one not so much right yeah so
it kind of teaching or training and i
always got stuck with a sir i'm not
gonna say his name but a certain person
and he was like ah two or two years
older than me
and we would sit and we we would get
totally [ __ ] drunk on the on the line
right like and it was so natural
and we'd be like because there was like
boxes and boxes boxes yeah it's like
boxes of like franzia yeah
exactly and so we would be we would be
drinking and the the most horrible part
about it is that um our priest he loved
to have it really warm in the front of
the church because he was like really
cold all the time so it was so
[ __ ] hot but we would be like
we would like be sweating wine and we
would be so wasted like here we here we
are we're like we're teenagers right and
we're just so [ __ ] wasted on unwind
just like just it pouring out of out of
us i don't know how he did it but he did
an exact hour on mass like an exact
[ __ ] hour he started and like the you
could watch the [ __ ] second hand
click to an hour when you were right
right at the end of the aisle and and
church was over and mass is over i don't
know how he did it but he did it every
single time exactly an hour so you would
watch the clock and you just be sweating
and the room would be [ __ ] spinning
so much because you were so drunk but it
was
sweating cheap wine yeah we're sweating
deep wine so that's mine
soak it up with the uh with the cheap
crackers yeah that's right and and now
you're doing god's work that's right
yeah
i guess and maybe i guess if you want to
put it that way yeah and you know you
know maybe if you have issues with
remembering the hail mary you can
obviously go and recite that cult prayer
that actually mike flynn was doing
instead of that you know what came on
when i was uh uh driving around today
was black flags i was so wasted and so
that's even better like i know all the
lyrics to that i
was so awake yeah that's it it i was
wasted yeah that's easier
what question are we on gabe four okay
so
uh let's see that was
two no three
three zero she is beating you three zero
nice nice uh there's no way you can
recover from this well let's let's go
ahead and let's see how many points
heidi can get i'm sure she'll all right
i might throw you one we'll see oh no
thanks i appreciate it
okay question number four which of the
following is not a romance language a
german b french c portuguese or d
italian uh uh german
yeah
there we go we got it right well done
i speak german so i know i know it's not
a romance language that is one that is
that does not roll off the tongue easily
so give us so give us some some uh some
crude words in german then let's hear
some
how would you how would you say [ __ ]
them in germany there you go you know
what's beautiful about german is you say
[ __ ] them [ __ ] them they they love they
they love our slang no i'll give you a
really gorgeous german word krunken
house
means hospital [ __ ] house hospitals
i'll give you another gorgeous german
word
which just means perfect which means pen
i mean why do they why do they have such
[ __ ] long words for such
that's incredible i love it
they're funny people but you know what's
great about germans is they make great
americans and my parents made great
americans and they're from germany so
go there we we are glad they came here
and that
you are here now
to not only fight fascism with us but to
play trivia yeah
yeah okay and actually you're gonna beat
me
a good segue here uh
for penn
is the final question okay which of the
following is a real author name and not
a pen name
a mark twain b george orwell c f scott's
fitzgerald or d lewis carroll i'm going
to guess f scott fitzgerald ding ding
ding not a winner
and the reason is that he really was
what he wrote about he was kind of from
that you know elite world and so
f scott fitzgerald is a very pompous
name so it seems legit
he was a he was a terrible drunk but he
was even worse when he was sober oh my
god i'm so glad i didn't fail and i was
a music writer for many many years
that's how i made my living so if i had
gotten the music one wrong like that
would have been just so humiliating
we are so glad we are so glad that you
came on and play trivia with us
thank you thank you for joining us and i
want you to come back and and bring all
the radicalized um co-hosts with you
eventually we want to have them on and
talk to them and ask them some of these
questions
my merry band is
hackers yeah absolutely yeah so tell us
this yes oh yeah we want them to ra or d
radical whichever it is yeah well we're
trying to radicalize people back to
that's right cool that's right
back normal back to cool yeah yeah right
so
so tell us before we leave because i
want you to tell us where to find you
where to find your podcast uh tell us
about that where to find you is this a
trick question
um
so
so first i just wanted i'm not trying to
dock you
first i want to say um thanks for
inviting the girl on because usually
like the girl doesn't get invited to
this [ __ ] everyone just thinks about the
dudes so on behalf of the dudes who are
stoked you invited the girl on i just
wanted to say thank you very much well
you can tell the dudes we are happy to
have the girl on yeah this was this is
so great thank you for coming on the
show oh i i had a ball and i can't wait
to come back and i will bring my uh
merry band of [ __ ] posting hackers along
with me
um radicalized podcast on youtube
radicalized pod on tweeter
uh i believe we can be found a
radicalized podcast on spotify and
anchor
and um
i think we even have a website which is
probably radicalized podcast but uh
uh i can be found on twitter at heidi
underscore cuda cuda jim stewartson all
one word with an o at the end
hi-fi underscore the 16th and the reason
he's hi-fi the 16th is because he's been
banned 15 other times
he he's the only guy in our crew who got
uh kicked off a twitter by a russian
gangster and so he's been fighting he's
been fighting back hard that's a story i
can't wait to have hi-fi on to ask you
about his russian gangster kicking him
off twitter he's fantastic wonderful
uh and then sean connor at sean connor
c-o-n-n-e-r-2023
uh he is our brilliant um
uh artist resident artist and musician
the cartoons at the end are all uh
coming from sean's incredible brain and
so i just want to thank you so much for
having me on i want you guys to stay rad
and i want you to keep doing this very
important work
why right i appreciate again you're
welcome back anytime and we want to have
your your uh merry band of men
but we definitely we definitely wanted
to have the woman on first because
let's face it if let's face it women are
much better than men and until and until
we hand over this world that men have
been [ __ ] up for so long and two
women i believe we're just gonna still
continue to [ __ ] it up so i hope women
take take power and take control and and
uh mother us out of this mess that these
men have made so that's how i that's how
i believe i believe that uh
wholeheartedly i have a daughter and i
hope she's part of that uh part of that
mothering of the world that takes us out
of this hellhole that men have put us in
so thank you for being here oh and and
thank you again i've been watching the
radicalized podcast and it is it is
fantastic you guys got to go watch over
there they do drop a lot of knowledge
you guys are on for about an hour or so
each one of those episodes and there's
so much stuff that you can find out uh
even the video that we played earlier
that jim had made was in one of those
episodes and there's so much more
content that lives inside those episodes
so go follow uh radicalized podcast
on youtube and go follow him on twitter
do not miss this thing because um you're
you're gonna want even though i watch it
in like double time so that i can watch
more yeah you guys so like i'm so used
to youtube you're gonna die of
consumption you are that's that's
probably what it is that's probably what
it is why i i'm so used to i it was kind
of weird talking to you today because
you're talking in half your speed that i
know i'm used to hearing you in and i'm
talking fast today because you sure i
really talk
thank you for joining us we had so much
fun and uh
com stay with us be right back with the
tony michael's podcast don't go anywhere
thank you heidi for joining us thank you
gentlemen
[Music]
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess
well now there's boycott binder the
ingenious organizer that keeps track of
everything and everyone you've ever
boycotted the 72 category filing system
makes it easy to organize boycotted
people places and things so you can find
them with ease the large centered area
can even fit your boycott sign but best
of all when you're done the boycott
binder folds right up so you can take it
anywhere so if you're tired of having a
cluttered mess call now and get the
boycott binder for just 29.99
plus you'll also receive our next rep as
a bonus just loop it around your neck to
travel with ease but call right now and
we'll double the offer that's two
boycott binders and two neck straps for
just 29.99
boycott binders brought to you by the
same makers of binders full of women
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at
twitch.tv slash the tony michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back
thanks for staying with us with the
interview fantastic interview by the way
fantastic fantastic interview gabe what
did you think of the interview
[Music]
i thought yeah yeah you gotta turn your
microphone on there oh there we go yeah
there we are now we're back yeah there
you go that beautiful voice that i don't
have yeah
uh no i thought it was great hide it
heidi uh uh heidi was wonderful i was so
so glad to have her on um i felt like
she could have
dropped even more on us
during that interview like we probably
could have gone a lot a lot longer
uh chatting with absolutely and we do we
do have a little bit of an extended
interview with her afterwards but yeah
it was um
it was great i i i had an amazing time
i'm super excited to have her and the
rest of her
uh [ __ ] posting hackers you know yeah
well you know i i i can't wait either
because i i really would like to uh you
know pick apart like that video that jim
had posted and he put together a mike
flynn and uh i think her name was
prophet i forget her full name but the
uh
the cult leader lady from the 80s
how he how he found this video of her
and he like he clips it together it's
it's actually kind of scary that that
yeah that they're doing these type of
things on purpose like
it it really is terrifying
yeah i would have never known uh had she
not or you brought it up you know or
rather jim like the ability to find that
right clip right
very
very impressive but also yeah it's scary
what they're saying and what they're you
know getting away with saying without
people understanding the source material
and that's that's why like some people
will say like oh you shouldn't post this
or you shouldn't show this and i'm like
uh i don't know i don't know that we we
shouldn't not see some of this stuff
because if jim wouldn't have put that
together mike flynn could keep keep
going to these places and literally
duping these people into saying these
cult like seance type things
whatever the [ __ ] that is i don't even
know what the hell you call that it's so
you know wacky but yeah well i mean it's
none of your squirrel turds but i mean
if we don't know that he's saying this
and these people don't know that he's
duping them how in the [ __ ] do we
unravel all this craziness that that
they're that they're you know these
fascists are piling on top of us
yeah it's um
you know you made it you brought up a
good point which is like when people
like oh don't post that don't share that
i get that all the time you know in
different tweets if i'm like doing a
video and i'm calling out whatever's
happening or
or uh
you know i'll take a screenshot of a
tweet because i don't want to really
boost that person right um
post
but i'll have people who come to me and
they're like oh why are you sharing the
white person it's like well if i don't
do it
you know and if we all don't do it
then how people
and yes it is unfortunate that we do
live in this time where
we have such misinformation or
disinformation or
uh or bad actors who are trying to
manipulate grift and con others
but if no one is talking about it then
it's going to keep happening and they
won't be held accountable or there won't
be some sort of justice to
to
knock them down a peg or two or
several you know right the old saying
goes sunlight is the best disinfectant
right and and that's and that well i
mean yeah you know yeah uh
a good example and a lot of people don't
like bill maher but do you remember milo
unopolis right he was getting his book
deal and there was this whole hoopla of
bill maher having him on his show but
bill maher has him on his show
interviews him and he like disappears
now he's kind of back in this in the in
the uh so he's in a conversion he's got
the conversion center or whatever now
right but he's almost he's almost well
yeah it's a grift but he's almost like
he's almost like anti-q anon anti not
really anti-trump but he's trying to
find his place and the only thing milo
annopolis knows how to do is to spread
[ __ ] right he doesn't know anything else
well i mean he's you know breitbart he's
a breitbart baby you know right right
well that's where he's born from and
it's yeah right
he's going to continue to be a [ __ ] bum
just because that's the cloth that he's
cut from but you know it is what it is
and then i get like you said you get
this all the time where you you'll post
something like a video of a marjorie
taylor green or bobert and they're like
you know people come in the comments and
they'll say you're giving her a platform
i'm like no she has a platform i'm
trying to show you what she's saying to
other people on that platform like if
you don't if you just because you don't
like hear no evil see no evil speak no
evil that's not a that's not a [ __ ]
that's a recipe for
really that's right yeah i don't know
what happened to nazi germany
yeah the the whole out of sight out of
mind is a very naive way of going
forward now you might want to distance
yourself from certain news because
you're like listen this is super toxic
and it's caused me a lot of stress and
anxiety totally understand that however
there are people like heidi and others
and you know jim and the rest of that
crew and like ourselves who are
calling attention to certain things
because it needs to be said and if it's
not then other people then it's going to
continue to go down
just a snowball effect of you know
the bigger
well yeah drawing more and more people
in without them knowing that this is
complete utter [ __ ] right right i
mean it's just it's it's crazy ass
nonsense and there's so much news that
we missed
this week and i i apologize not giving
more on the [ __ ] list but i felt like
today was a good day
uh to really dive into
uh what we need to do about this gun
culture and that's kind of this q anon
stuff you know drawing people into this
this just this utter nonsense where we
have to put up with our children killing
our children and it it it's it's
frustrating but if we don't
talk about it if we don't say these
things
uh these people
won't know that they're being duped by
these right-wing fascists i i believe i
believe so yeah
at one one it's a couple other things
before we leave uh number one go follow
heidi on twitter it's heidi kuda and uh
also follow their podcast uh radicalized
they got a twitter account and they also
have a youtube account and and i think
she said you can find it on spotify and
anchor um so go check their podcast out
there i think they do one like every
week it's like an hour long and i think
they're on episode four i've watched uh
three of them i believe and they're
really good they got all four they're
like she said it's it's heidi and then
her band of uh mary hackers or whatever
or whatever she referred to
band of merry [ __ ] posters and hackers
[ __ ] posting hector yes yes that's it so
so go check the go check them out and
and then follow uh her band of
merry [ __ ] posting hackers as well
because you definitely want to you
definitely want to pay attention to
their feeds because they have a lot of
this stuff in there that you really need
to be paying attention to of what what
these people are
are saying on their platforms to their
followers to dupe them into these ideas
and also go vote for bonehead of the
week uh remember uh here i'll i'll put
it up here's our bonehead uh candidates
of the week marjorie taylor green lurie
gomer and thomas massey it's actually a
lot closer race than it was last week
last week lauren bober ran away with
this thing yeah she blew it out of the
water right that's right and i would
you know maybe she saw you know uh
bonehead of the week and she was like
listen i want to get back on that and
then she released that right you know
right right well maybe that's what it
was so so it go vote for you you can
vote for it at tony michael's pod the
podcast twitter account uh or you can go
to miner gabe's account and there's a
link there at our on our bio to go to
and vote and and we'll do at both end of
the week this weekend episode to tell
you who won and kind of break down why
these people were on the bone end of the
week also uh go follow gabe's account at
i am gabe sanchez on twitter tic tac
instagram all the all the socials and
then i'm at the tony michaels follow me
there
uh until next week
because i'll be on tomorrow for the
shitless roundup thursday and friday but
until next week wednesday three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern live here
on youtube twitter twitch i just have to
say i just have to say [ __ ] them what do
you have to say gabe any any any last
words
[ __ ] them
[ __ ] em
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]